so Tina Fey Margot Robbie and Bilbo
Baggins walk into Kabul no this isn't
the setup to a terrible joke it's the
plot to phase new movie
whiskey-tango-foxtrot the film is based
on TV journalist Kim Barker's
simultaneously funny and sad memoir the
Taliban shuffle about her time as a war
correspondent in Afghanistan and
Pakistan it's a lot more good morning
Vietnam than Apocalypse Now
WTF yes that title is intentional starts
with phase Kim being sent to Kabul where
she's confronted with the messy
realities of embedding in a war zone she
makes friends with Margot Robbie's Tania
Vanderpool and photographer Ian Mykelti
played by Martin Freeman see we told you
Bilbo was in on this joke but just as
she learns to love the adrenaline tinged
life of a war correspondent she begins
to realize the terrible realities in
Afghanistan and the ickiness of trying
to get ratings from them this movie
could have easily fumbled by trying to
wring too many laughs out of war
what still 5 Mikes media it must be
dumping out get my pants on but just
when it almost goes too far it stops on
a dime like a perfectly timed punchline
that's not to say whiskey-tango-foxtrot
is perfect coming as it does on the
heels of Oscars so white it's
unfortunate to see Kim's Afghan fixer
played by someone whose last major role
was literally James White in James
White's ad story I've ever heard
whiskey-tango-foxtrot is far from being
the whole picture of the war in
Afghanistan but what it does show it
shows an very sharp focus